so the the problem
with multiculturalism is that there's
too much islam
in britain it's too much islam
now first of all i love diversity
i'm very easily bored i've got a short
attention span
and i love experiencing new things um
i love trying new food discovering new
literature art
and finding out about other people's
customs and traditions that's wonderful
i love diversity
i hope everyone does because life would
be very boring otherwise
and that's one reason why we all travel
you know you want to go to a different
country
to be immersed in the sights and the
sounds and the smells of that country
the language the food
you want to see the architecture you
want to see the place the current place
in time
which the history has brought them to
that people in that land
that's traveling that's how you travel
but in london in a place like london
today which is
a multicultural [__] you come here
and there's nothing that's specifically
unique nothing uniquely english about
it so
i mean what would be uniquely english
anyway has like the little pubs
the beer the football
it may not sound like much but it's
english you know
the difference between london and new
york in terms of multiculturalism
i lived in new york when i was younger
for six years
and yes in new york you know you have
different
areas different boroughs that um
different cultures different groups of
people have settled in
and they've brought the flavor of their
culture
to that area to that borough with an
irish
spanish mexican they've brought
something of their own culture
to the new culture for everyone else to
everyone else to enjoy
and participate in when you live in new
york you can go to the irish area
the italian area and they're all fun
places to hang out
and to drink and to have food and to
meet new people
it's all great but that's not the case
in london
you know in london
what we're seeing with too much islam
is that outlying boros the minute you
leave central london
the trafalgar square current garden area
chelsea's an exception
majority of outlying london boroughs are
turning into
the cultural wastelands
places like um stephanie green white
chapel woolwich
from paddington you go seven miles up
the harrow road
towards harold's in wembley and beyond
even all the way east end all the way to
elford
cultural with desert lands wastelands
there's no reason to go there
because it's heavily islamic and
even moving shepherd's bush out as well
when a place becomes too heavily islamic
what you see
is that fun things cease to exist pubs
close down
the high street changes when an area
becomes too heavily islamic
what you see is that the fun things
cease to exist
or they become very sparse and people
say oh well you can still go to
white chapel today but you give white
chapel five more years
and there's no reason to go there gay
people i know don't go nearby chapel has
nothing to do
the high street has changed in areas
that are heavily islamic what you see
the shops are comprised there's not much
more than
rotting fruit and veg burkas
halal butchers there's a mosque an
islamic bookstore
that's generally there's not much more
on offer that's essentially all they
have
another problem i have with these
islamic areas people say there's no go
zones in london
they're not really no-go zones they're
kind of tread carefully
zones because at night time
and even during the day it's it's very
patriarchal it's very
heavily handed mail what's visible
what's
on the street is predominantly male
gangs of men
so that's not for me that's not fun
there's no diversity there it's just
there's all men i don't like that
and they work at get back to the worker
you know
people say it's inclusive all the rest
of it if i see someone in the bar
that's a closed door that's a brick wall
at no point am i enticed
to go up to a personal barco and say hi
or
can you tell me where such and such is
or do you have the time
it's a closed door it's a brick wall
it's saying keep back
i don't want to know you that's about
this is i think god knows what they're
saying beneath that burka they've been
mouthing at you
you [__] [__] you don't know what
they're saying you don't know what's
going on
culturally for my culture the parka has
no place
and also people going with immigration
immigration well you know when i went to
new york
i was an illegal immigrant even though
i'd find a woman who was
willing to employ me and she took me to
a lawyer
and we tried to get the green card to
work in papers but at that point in my
life i hadn't yet been to university i
didn't have a degree so i was
considered to be an unskilled worker and
so they wouldn't take me in
that was fair news i didn't stomp i just
stayed
um you know i didn't think it was a
racial issue nothing like that
and also now that i'm living in england
is still britain but still i'm scottish
i could can be considered to be an
immigrant in england no
i could do a lot of other immigrants are
doing i could be recreating
a mini scotland in england i could be
screaming for scottish law
to be applied on english people i could
be
forcing haggis and shortbread down
everyone's throats but i'm not i've come
to england
to experience english culture if i
wanted to be immersed in scottish
culture i would have stayed in scotland
and my work to other immigrants is that
if you're so
if you're if you're so nostalgic and if
you're missing your homeland so much
you need to go back to it and leave
england alone
let it be
um so yeah
multiculturalism immigration diversity
someone said to me well you can't stop
change things change
and that's amazing i love it we all need
change things have to go
forward but whenever change happens
you hope that the change is for the
better not for the worst
and the change that we're seeing in
britain today is for the worst it's not
for the better